the U.N Secretary General is calling for
Global action against Miss and
disinformation we'll call for Action
from everyone with influence on the
spread of means and this information on
the internet
governments Regulators policy makers
technology companies the media Civil
Society
stop the hate
set up strong guard rails be accountable
for language that causes harm
and as part of my report or common
agenda we are convening all stakeholders
around the code of conduct for
information Integrity on digital
platforms
and will also further strengthen our
focus on our means and this information
are impacting progress on global issues
including the climate crisis the means
and these information and of course
missing this information just means
anything that contradicts The Narrative
of the liberal Elite on any given day